we've all heard the criticisms of
President Trump which go something like
this no president has come close to
defaming and trying to destroy the
democratic values of this country no
president has come close see no he's
tearing down these institutions does he
know he's there any doubt he shatters
norms for a living how much longer can
we survive the autocratic tendencies of
one man this is revealing his autocratic
tendencies Donald Trump has no no real
commitment to democracy no no all the
other team it's the commitment to
democracy that's why they're always
trying to undermine it and undo the
election look if any of that were true
why on earth would president Trump
nominate a man like Bill Barr is it his
attorney general Oh Barr no matter what
you think he's a mainstream safe pick
he's a consummate Pro who served in the
Reagan administration and later as
George HW Bush's counsel the Department
of Justice before being promoted to
attorney general now full disclosure
he's a friend don't hold that against
him but the bottom line is he knows the
legal terrain really well and he even
oversaw the Robert Muller guy that were
focused on once before when Muller was
head of do J's Criminal Division and if
there's any question about bars
independence well that was put to rest
at today's hearing what would be your
breaking point when would you pick up
and leave when is your Jim mattis moment
when the president has asked you to do
something but you think is inconsistent
with your oath I am NOT gonna do
anything that I think is wrong and I
will not be bullied into doing anything
I think is wrong by anybody whether it
be editorial boards or Congress or the
president I'm gonna do what I think is
right oh and as for the Democratic
drumbeat that Trump only selects people
he can control and who essentially agree
to I don't know some sort of loyalty
pledge president Trump has sought no
assurances promises or commitments from
me of any kind either express or implied
and I have not given him any other than
that I
would run the department with
professionalism and integrity
now bar testified that he wants Muller
to complete his probe and has confidence
in Muller's professionalism but that
wasn't enough for some like Senator Pat
Leahy who tried to get bar 2 vowed to
recuse himself from oversight of the
Muller probe if the staff at the DOJ
suggests he do so so will you commit if
confirmed to both seeking and following
advice of the partners career ethics
officials and whether you must recuse
from the special counselors
investigation I I will seek the advice
of the career ethics personnel but under
the regulations I make the decision as
the head of the agency as to my own
recusal so I would consult with them and
and at the end of the day I would make a
decision in good faith based on the laws
and the facts that are evident at that
time I'm sorry we're all sitting here in
the studio he reminds me so much of
Justice Scalia just his inflection and
the way he reacts to questions I just
brought it back it was odd anyway it's
clear that Barr is his own man and
contrary to some of the nasty tweets out
there tweets from the right like this
well Scott Dennis says I don't trust
Barr he seems awfully cozy with many of
the people surrounding the whole Spygate
scandal all right I get I get the
concern but all I can say is this I've
known var for 20-plus years he's a man
of deep integrity and he has a really
strong intellect we need that today at
the Department of Justice and he comes
at a very important time in the life of
all of these law enforcement agencies he
sees his job and what I think is the
correct light why do you want this job
well because I love the department a lot
and and all its components including the
FBI I think they're critical
institutions that are essential to
preserving the rule of law which is the
heartbeat of this country doing it
because he loves the country to do this
sixty-eight years old go be on a beach
somewhere wants to serve the nation well
bill Barr couldn't assume this job of
Attorney General fast enough especially
given the revelations of the FBI's war
against this president remember was just
last Friday that we learned about
another sickening effort by certain bad
actors inside the bureau to target the
president remember after Peter Struck's
insurance policy failed to prevent Trump
from winning the White House commis FBI
cronies pulled another surprise out of
its bag of tricks they launched an
unconstitutional and unprecedented
counter-intel investigation of the
sitting president they should all be
fired at least those who are still
working within the department well by
the way this was supposedly done get
this because Trump fired Comey which of
course if they read their little pocket
Constitution the president was fully
entitled to do under article 2 of the
Constitution now the Inspector General's
final report should expose all of this
can't wait and as if things couldn't get
more poisonous we learned today that the
former general counsel of the FBI James
Baker himself is under investigation for
media leaks against President Trump
turns out he was in regular contact with
Mother Jones leftist writer David corn
are they still publishing well it's just
a coincidence I'm sure it it was the he
remember it was the first to report on
that phony steel dossier you know the
thing that was the predicates used to
start the entire Trump Russia probe bar
understands the danger inherent in a
Department of Justice that becomes its
own political strike force and the
danger of criminalizing politics and of
overzealous prosecutors the prosecutor
comes along and says well
we're gonna look into your mind and see
what your subjective intent was for
performing these two sets of lawful acts
and we're gonna say you know that you're
corrupt so I just think that gives too
much power to the prosecutor totally
agree even separate from what has
happened to President Trump if Democrats
really cared as they claim about the
rule of law and restoring the public's
faith in the Justice Department they
would welcome with open arms the
nomination of bill Barr but because many
of them not all but many are infected
with this anti Trump virus everyone
Trump nominates every idea that Trump
has must be resisted or the individuals
involved at least bruised in the process
but today they didn't lay a glove on
Bill Barr and that's the angle